hey how's it going so a lot of you guys
always ask me how i make videos or how
to take photos or just you guys ask me a
lot of questions about making videos and
the funny thing is is there is this
misconception with a lot of you guys
that watch
a lot of people's youtube videos myself
included that it's an extremely
glamorous process that there's a studio
there's lights there's
magic some people well they're lucky
enough to have that but i
on the other hand i have never really
had like a crazy studio set up or
anything i'm almost glad that i do this
stuff alone because if anybody really
saw me do this well you guys are gonna
see it now but if you've watched this
process in real life
i think i'm kind of crafty but i also
look like a crazy person but i wanted to
share this with you as i was doing this
and taking these photos of myself i i
needed to show you this because
i'm just gonna shut up and just show you
what it's like so using this tripod to
focus my camera and then i put it on a
10 second timer and then it takes the
picture okay
okay should i show you guys this from
another angle how stupid i look
okay
focus
[Music]
i'm going to try and clean up my room i
was in the process of packing for london
and then i was like crap i need to shoot
some videos before i leave
and that's why there's uh
that's why there's a mess everywhere but
that's just an excuse i'm a slob and a
hoarder so see you guys later bye
[Music]